it is 6 23 am
and taika
is about to have okay
this amazing
delicious delicious cake
scrumdilious cake cake
yum dude okay and as you can tell
we are not home
we are currently in our Airbnb we're
gonna pour the forks
we're gonna be here
for a few months
but I'll explain that in a bit I want to
see you enjoy it
okay I'm still tracking macros of this
right here
yeah is it good
you can try that part I like how you eat
cake dude break all the rules
it's not yucky cheesecake's the best
what do we think what about the whipped
cream can you get a little bit of the
whipped cream
is it perfect
oh so happy for YouTube yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh I would have done the same bite
dude I would have done the same bite
okay okay what else what else you doing
what else are you doing what else he
doing I'm thinking oh good in the front
I'm gonna break the car
I break a glass you did
oh
wow
these are the glass is breaking from the
car
[Music]
the cake is bended
I'm so happy you like cheesecake
okay so excuse the appearance because I
know
I look crazy but like I said 6am
beautiful
thank you dude
6 a.m Bart woke up at five because he's
gonna be in Sacramento today for this um
powerlifting event called Power Fest up
in California up in the bay so it's
gonna be me grandma
me grandma and taka today Grandpa ended
up going back to California so he's
gonna stay out there now
um for a bit so moving forward in our
Vlogs grandpa is no longer going to be
living with us
um he just did the Vegas life figured it
really wasn't for him but I'll give you
the whole rundown cheese mint in another
Vlog this Vlog we're just gonna talk
about our move today's the last day of
um going back to our now old house and
making sure everything's clean for the
new buyers because their walk through
um their final walkthrough is tomorrow
and if everything checks out then we can
close meaning
we are done the house is no longer ours
it's theirs so it's going to be a
fun-filled day for us but first let me
give you a tour because this place is so
cute
right I think you said you'd love it
here right
oh oh
better not don't do it
oh oh I want to do the same thing put my
face in that cake yeah that's gonna be
funny
yeah because
and then to the scroll down and then one
fall down on the food
on the food too
on their face oh my God
it's like you're still trying to find us
laughing here that I love it every day
is a different life
[Music]
yeah we're sitting like an owl dude
you're so cute
to me okay Okay so
um this is the entrance of our house
no it's not
oh okay okay my mistake
okay so this is our little living room
and again this is an Airbnb so none of
this stuff belongs to us but it's cute
isn't it then you have your little
dining area
and then you have your little kitchen
area
and like we have way too much goddamn
food I didn't realize like
this
and then I already filled this up this
is all like a macro friendly
food here look at this we're [ __ ]
ridiculous who needs so much freaking
food
s okay well that obviously is not diet
we gotta get some snacks for the monkey
dude
yeah foreign
okay
and then out here we have like this
little balcony section
overlooking
other people's properties
oh yummy okay then we walk over here and
it's like they called it a third room
definitely not a third room
or like bedroom it is a room technically
but um yeah this will probably be a
little makeshift office
so that's cool right
and then
at first I thought this was like a doggy
door I don't know what it is
but I can't open it
it's in here
we got storage closets with
with magazines in there weird
an iron cleaning stuff
okay hallway
Mom's room is there we'll give her a
minute leave her alone this is
bathroom
pretty sizable bathroom actually
super cute
over here what is this I forgot this is
oh yeah laundry room whoops
yeah laundry room
[Music]
and then you can walk down here
and then down there is our garage I'll
show you what that looks like actually
I love it everything is so
cute
here
a garage is a joke you can only fit two
motorcycles in here
definitely not a car I don't know what
they made this garage for but it ain't a
car garage
yeah all of our [ __ ] this is what we're
gonna live off of
for three months not that pile
that's stuff I ate gave my mom that
she's taking back home but like from
that line This Way is our stuff
so it's like that whole box right there
is taika's toys pots and pans which I'm
just like why did I even I should have
just packed it it's a [ __ ] Airbnb but
whatever this stuff right here is not
ours this is the Airbnb peoples
but yeah you know
the and this isn't even ours oh right
there's a pool here okay
just surrounding myself okay
[Applause]
you want to help me you're done with
your you want to help me give a tour
okay show let's show my room where's my
room at
and then this is
our room
over here brought just
my little shoes
you can open these guys up get some
natural light this is one thing I like
about this house
um there's a lot of natural light that
comes in we're also by a freeway I think
because I can hear a lot of cars
okay let's show the closet
I do it's that door
look at this closet so cool
it's super cool so closet look they also
have some some clothes some buns what
are those called hangers yep but these
ones are different yeah these don't
these aren't ours pop aside these ones
are all those ones are brand new because
those ones are gray oh is that weather
new and the other ones are black got it
okay and then what else is that whoa
whoa what else is next
inside there's a room in here what are
you talking about
is a room
there's a poo poo room wait how do I
turn on this light oh here we go
no no
yeah and then shower that's it
cute right it's a cute little house no
I'm not going to show you
so inappropriate but yeah this is our
next house for the next couple months
right like about a month and a half we
uh we had to get it for at least three
months so we will have this place for I
think
one week into November
um but our other house should be
finished by October so we're good we're
in a good position
um super cute spot our house
is being built and almost wrapped we
have a walkthrough on that like how way
to bring you and see all of our
finishing touches because this house is
the perfect everything we wanted
okay okay we're done
now I'm back at the original House empty
do you want to see it
it's really empty okay like
almost empty but like all of our stuff
is gone but first taika wanted to share
his cake pop you want a Starbucks to get
some fuel
I unfortunately am still cutting so I
just got a Nitro cold brew
that's it oh do you want to tell grandma
what
her chai tastes like
what
no your her try her coffee her tea
remember what happened
tell her what happened
so what happened
oh my God and which one is better are we
going
nice yeah
tiger was like Can I taste your coffee
I'm like dude you do not want to taste
them he goes trust me I want taste and I
was like all right taste it he tried and
he was immediately like what pieces you
make
[Music]
and then I was like you want to try
grandma's and then your face was like
yeah I would have made the same face
dude even when I'm drinking it I'm going
I just needed to wake up anyway let me
show you the house
so here it is
we never even got to use this room
uh we're not so anything that you see
here any little stragglers those are
just the things that we're not bringing
with us anymore uh we have 1 800 junk uh
people picking it up today so yeah
brought this from our Airbnb and it
doesn't work like it left look at this
it left
more mess than it picked up so
dude but the Dyson it moves really good
like my first impression of how easy
this thing is to use is awesome
but my first impression of how easy it
is to break is also like I'm not going
to invest on it but it moves so cool
this is my first Dyson product I've ever
used like the way it maneuvers
is pretty neat and it seems pretty
intuitive in terms of use but I feel
like I'm gonna break it because it's too
dainty and I know the price tag on like
a Dyson so I'm just like is it worth the
stress
because of the money I spent and I'm
trying to take care of this thing and
this thing's supposed to pick up trash
like I shouldn't feel intimidated by it
but I do is that like a credit card in
there oh no it's a slot I was like what
the heck
um okay moving on
whoa whoa fast guy whoa
yeah this room empty
under the stair storage
[Applause]
empty I sold them these shelves because
honestly
I don't want to bring them with me I
don't want to bring a lot of the stuff I
even sold them our bunk beds because I'm
just like what else do you want to buy
off of us
I want to move
so
bunk beds sold so those stayed with them
um
just waiting whoa
whoa let's go upstairs yeah
what
[Music]
okay so upstairs this is everything that
was in our podcast room and look at how
cute we are
because we had built our own podcast
yep we had built our own podcast set
we all signed it even taika whoops look
at that
that's his signature right there folks
so if you want to forward some checks
screenshot
so yeah let's go into podcast room this
area is getting patched up
see
all the holes and stuff this is what the
room looks like
oh what the hell they said they were
supposed to be here at nine but they're
here now so I gotta go guys
but yeah this is what our broadcast room
used to look like but let me come back
because they're here to pick up my junk
all of this stuff
they literally told me they were coming
9 30 to 10. they're here ma
'am so there we go
they're taking on my junk
look at this
so
bar had one task and it was to empty
this damn thing out he ended up just
stabbing it the water's still in it so
monkey doodle you wanna do something fun
okay stand inside of come here
I need you to stand inside of it so the
water comes up
can I can I jump sure sure
yeah you wanna take your shoes off
[Music]
okay and your socks okay take off your
shoes and your socks no take off your
shoes and your socks
here I'll help you I'll help you I'll
help you I'll help you awesome huh it's
gonna be so funny it's gonna be funny
because I put my feet in the water yeah
the water's clean here
wait wait wait oh you want to not use
your Crocs okay take it off go for it
just step on it we need to
okay
we need the water out you can do this
dude
go go
well I don't need you to get your view
why don't you get the water out go step
on it the whole thing
good job it's working
it's working
I have a feeling you're gonna fall in
there
okay now I think you're just making a
pool
inside of a pool
[Applause]
down okay let me see let me see if I can
roll it out
there you go
good job
good job good job
okay let me help you okay so while that
gets emptied out or they continue doing
their job I think we got the hot tub
situation
settled let me show you the rest of the
house that's empty
yay there's a bunch of junk here as they
picked it up that's actually a really
cool service
if you guys are interested in it
definitely not sponsored but I think
they charge you per weight of the truck
so like if I threw out all my gym
equipment it'd be really really
expensive because it's gonna weigh tons
um
making it all nice
um and then they do charge you per
volume used up within the truck
so I think this straw might be anywhere
around 600 bucks to a thousand bucks
so just kind of pricey but peace of mind
people you trust you know the work's
gonna be good
that's kind of vet but uh
yeah
take his room
empty
all gone
empty
for here
completely empty
yeah so we lived here so
so
short
amount of time we didn't really get to
settle in very much
but I ain't mad
yeah there was just a lot of unused
space but I never know what to do with
like that area I'm like
the [ __ ] do people put there so we had
this extra couch and I'm like
but I didn't want to sit there because
my bed is here I'd rather just sit and
[ __ ] chill in my bed what the [ __ ] I
need a couch or whatever the [ __ ] this
space is like I ain't that [ __ ] rich
[ __ ] you know what I mean like I'm just
a regular ass chick
that just needs regular ass space like
it was cool to experience this house for
sure
but
I do not need two goddamn bathrooms like
why
why we really didn't use them
this guy was so abandoned because we had
that guy and like this never used it
because I always feel so guilty wasting
so much water this though like two sinks
yeah baby but this whole Space
unnecessary but wait wait can we just
check out the games real quick can we
just check out the games real quick
okay moving on
see closet space
done this is what I used to have on my
shoes
as well
and this just used to be our office this
is one thing that's wrong with this
community
all of their windows are defected so the
next buyer which we've disclosed and the
property the people that are the
builders they've disclosed it too so at
no cost to anyone all of these windows
in every single house is going to get
replaced within this whole Community but
it's a bummer because this house is so
beautiful because of the windows and
there's so many windows there's like 80
plus windows in this house
it's gonna be a lot of work anyway
um this thing right here was pretty rad
we got our house hot hardwired because
as you know we upload and transfer a lot
of videos so internet for us is key
so plugging it into the actual
I don't know how internet works bro but
once it's hardwired it she got even
faster and we did like this mesh or net
system
um so the router can only reach so far
within the house and this is a pretty
sizable house so we got it
meshed
netted some [ __ ] like that we're now
like these things start like feeding off
of each other that ultimately feed off
of the router so that we can have solid
internet throughout the entire house
oh
so that's pretty red and
um yeah that's it our house is empty we
had literally like two weeks to get the
[ __ ] out of this house oh and the the
new buyers wanted to keep our washer and
dryer they were like yes
we don't because you know when you do
sell a house no one ever wants to or
when you go into negotiations you know
with money never no one ever wants to go
with the first amount that's thrown on
the table
um so they countered and then we
countered and then they countered and
then they were like fine we'll give you
your price that you're asking for
um but just throw in your washer and
dryer we're like
of course we've had this [ __ ] forever
and length how much are [ __ ] washers
and dryers please take it give us what
we're asking for so it made it even
better because that's something we don't
have to move with we've moved so goddamn
much you guys that like
we're experts at moving and we just
realized that like
the less we move with the better right
and you're like duh [ __ ] Common Sense
the less you have the faster you can
move duh of course but things like
washers and dryers which you think are a
necessity you
you're gonna get them cheaper you can
even get them used like right now I'm
like
I just don't want to [ __ ] move
anymore and this house
um
I was just about to say it might be the
one but it might not be the one you know
and they're just supposed to show you
you never know where life's gonna take
you and it's always key to staying
Nimble especially now like when we can
work from literally anywhere in the
world we want to so why not stay Nimble
stay flexible stay fluid my friends
who said that who said that